[MUSIC PLAYING]
Push notifications are
coming to web apps,
and one best practice that
just became an anti-pattern.
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is LazyWeb.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Chrome 42 hit
Stable this weekend.
With it comes a number
of new features.
Push notifications let users
opt into timely updates.
Install Banners prompt
users to save pages
to their home screen.
Permissions let you know
if you can use an API.
Fetch acts as a
replacement for XHR,
and it even includes
support for ES6 classes.
Jacob Kaplan-Moss, keynote
from this year's Pi Con
breaks some of the
dichotomy that developers
are either 10X badasses
or completely terrible.
Removing these assumptions
helps us better address
problems like impostor
syndrome and work
to improve potentially
toxic work environments.
Critical relative URLs
are now an anti-pattern.
Tweeted by Paul Irish this week,
the practice of leaving off
the protocol from a
URL is now discouraged,
as it can possibly lead to
man-on-the-side attacks similar
to the one that hit GitHub.
The new recommendation
is to always request
an asset over HTTPS if
it is available on SSL.
Check to see if your
site is mobile friendly.
A recent article on the
Google Webmaster's blog
indicates that
starting immediately,
Google search will add labels
next to sites that it considers
mobile friendly.
The criteria
includes such things
as making sure that users don't
have to zoom to read the page,
and links that are
spaced far enough apart.
You can use the
mobile friendly test
to ensure your site meets
the bar and skill up
over at Web Fundamentals.
Learning Git can be tough.
A look at Stackoverflow
reveals over 53,000 Git
related questions.
But help is on the way.
First Aid Git is
a searchable index
of the most commonly
asked Git questions.
Curious how to undo a
change that you've just
pushed to Master?
You can find that answer and
more, or submit a pull request
to add to the index.
60 frames per second is
the target for a smooth web
experience, but it's easy
to fall off the fast path.
Paul Lewis and Cameron
Pittman show you
how to optimize the four major
areas of your app-- Response,
Animate, Idle and Load, a.k.a.
RAIL-- in this free six
part Udacity course.
Blast Jank Invaders
and master dev tools
all while learning the
secrets to a faster web app.
That's it for this week.
I'll leave you with a
JavaScript screensaver.
As always, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]